so tell me about the the next layer of
your architecture you're doing some
interesting things on the on the data
side
um using nosql Technologies and other
things talk to me a little bit about
about that for every single bid request
we get in uh we actually have to do some
sort of storage lookup
um and um the way that is done actually
we have several
usually
two lookups per request so if we're
doing 25 in a second 25 000 requests per
second then we have to do about 50 000
lookups and also we do store information
about them so we have also a fairly
substantial write throughput
and this is like one of those obvious uh
situations where where traditional very
general database Technologies uh fall
through then we could we could probably
scale the reads pretty well up to that
amount but the rights would be very very
hard and also
because we're so latency constrained
having a general database engine to add
two three extra milliseconds it's just a
waste of time so because of this how
many different types of data stores do
you have
so we we have
um three types basically uh we have the
key value stores which is used for for
reads and writes during uh the time
critical bidding uh process then we have
traditional rdbms which is in our case
MySQL that we use for the more business
oriented the standard things that are
nice to put in a database so we have our
well ledgers and transaction logs for
for money flow not for for the the not
for the high frequency stuff but for the
more low frequency stuff
and then we also have
um more big data type store which we use
for doing analytics and queries on the
really really big data sets
we actually have a fourth we also have
uh or unstructured or they're actually
structured but we have just raw logs
that we can can run more mapreduce that
Hawk queries over if we're if everything
else fails okay
um and it's I think we spoke previously
you're looking at some different
solutions for
nosql data Stores
um talk to me a little bit about the
options there yeah so there are a lot of
options for uh for uh nosql right now
um
and um
yeah so first of all I I like the new
the new uh the new explanation for the
acronym NOW SQL which is not only SQL
and this is all about finding finding
the right tools for the job
um and the different mice and the
different nosql solutions are usually
fairly specialized and there are some
general ones like and and couched
DB that are fairly General nosql
Solutions and they also have their sweet
spots but in our case we were looking at
something
very very simple we just actually have
key and values that's all we need
something with extremely low latency
and something that performed uh
consistently and predictably
and we looked at a number of different
projects including open source projects
we actually started running
on open source projects I'm not going to
bash them right now but uh we ended up
actually going for a commercial vendor
okay which I'm not going to sell either
right now okay
um well yeah they're called Citrus Leaf
it's a really good company actually they
serve a lot of credit they they took our
a lot of the the Jitter in our
performance just right out of the
equation out of the equation it's a very
very simple yet very capable and nosql
solution that performs insanely well
and this is the stuff that we're running
on our SSD drives
in a fairly small cluster
but can still take an immense the
throughput is awesome okay so you
mentioned that
um
there's faster technology out there than
the typical map reduce Hadoop stack that
many Engineers are becoming familiar
with yeah um talk to me a little bit
more about the options there and and
what you guys are looking at so
um well first of all you have to well
mapreduce is just a principle on how you
can process or split Big Data into
smaller chunks and then process it in
parallel and then try to reduce it into
something meaningful in the end and
there are a lot of generalized mapreduce
Frameworks and the most well-known one
is called Hadoop which is basically a
it's a rather large stack of software
which is founded on the principle of
mapreduce
we started using
um Hadoop it does have some strength is
in that it's open source and it's fairly
easy to get started with
um
pretty we've had some issues running
into bugs it's fairly difficult to get a
everything up and running there
but it worked all right but we were
seeing for the things we do we need
shorter response times we needed to do
queries over really large data sets and
we just found out that Hadoop didn't
perform well enough for us we were using
Amazon's elastic mapreduce framework or
their their Cloud offering which also
works pretty well
but it just given didn't give us the
performance we wanted and the
fundamental reason for this is probably
or at least into a large degree that
when using Hadoop and you're using raw
log files underneath you actually have
to to if you have 30 terabytes of data
then you have to read 30 terabytes off
of disk
whereas very often you just wanna you
just want to pick
let's say one of the queries we might
run over this data set if you want to
see how what star over the course of a
month how many ad Impressions could we
sell to
iPhone users
in North America
and all we're interested in then is the
the platform we detected and and maybe
some IP ranges or dma or something like
that but just a couple of fields so
you're talking about selecting a value
out of uh just one column out of a data
set that might have many columns in the
row yeah so
um that's exactly it right and so Hadoop
is brute forcing a lot of these things
what you really want to do is just well
this is just
like the the poster boy for column or in
an oriented databases and there are a
few open source ones there too so hbase
is one but I guess sound rate is
probably one of the more well-known
there hpacing Cassandra there is an
interesting project going on that the
data sites guys are doing with running
Hadoop on top of Cassandra which then at
least takes away the storage and load i
o problem of the question
but it turns out that there are a lot of
um proprietary commercial vendors here
that offer solutions that still just
blows anything else out of the water
some of them are actually hybrid open
source as well like info brights based
on MySQL has a proprietary storage
engine
um and um
has a Community Edition but you actually
have to if you want we're not using them
but if you want to if you want it if you
want these Solutions you actually have
to pay for them okay
um at least for now and
um they use
compression
call an oriented storage and they just
it's
I recommend anybody that's looking for
analytics and especially real-time
analytics to take a look at these these
offerings I know that if we were trying
to do this with with something like
Hadoop
well we would have made it work we could
do Roll-Ups on a regular basis all those
kinds of traditional workarounds for it
but um with these Solutions you can
actually just run your queries in SQL
and they will respond in sub a second
even over hundreds of millions of rows
yeah and a couple of those players again
are so the the ones that we've been
looking at are our vertica info bright
as the data green plum
and another player called Vector advice
which is from Ingress okay so they all
perform incredibly well and they do
start to change a bit when you start
doing so we had two types of Big Data
basically we have the impression
tracking which is
based per per campaign
um that's still in the region of maybe a
couple hundred million rows that we do
analytics on and then we have this this
fire hose which is in the 30 billion row
uh region uh and when you start getting
up to those levels they start to to
differ a bit due to the way they're
architected some are easy to scale out
whereas the others actually have to be
scaled up
um so they're different but um they're
all worth the look